good morning
welcome to this joint overview and
scrutiny committee i am councillor mary
mclaren and i will be chairing the
meeting today
may i first of all remind you of some of
the domestic
arrangements please ensure that you
maintain social distancing from all of
the persons whilst in the chamber and in
the communal areas
please ensure that you wear a face
covering at all times unless you are
sitting down or if you are exempt from
doing so
and that you use the handset
hand sanitizer and wipes provided
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or are switched off
we will be using e-voting for this
meeting on the modern.gov dot app so
please could members make sure they are
logged in and ready to use the app
i would like to remind everyone present
at this meeting that it will be
broadcast live to the internet and will
be capable of repeated viewing the whole
of the meeting will be recorded
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council
members of the public and the press
may record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
if you hear the alarm
leave the building immediately via a
fire exit and make your way to the
assembly point
that is ipswich town football ground
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exit at each end of the floor
do not enter the atrium that is the
ground floor area and walkways
if you are in the atrium at the time of
the alarm follow the signs to the
nearest fire exit
use the stairs not the lifts
do not enter the building until told it
is safe to do so
can i just
um welcome
the following officers to this meeting
we have emily ewell monitoring officer
and
teresa halliday service manager for the
shared legal service
and
robert carmichael is our governance
officer in attendance
and i think
that is
everybody yes we have also vicki mosley
and royston uh emerson will be joining
for the citizens advice
okay
can i move to the agenda please
so
please can we have apologies and
substitutes
thank you chair we have apologies this
morning from councillor catherine
grandin and councillor keith scarf and
councilor stephen phillips is
substituting for councillor keith scarf
thank you
declaration of interest
councillor
muller
yes i should declare that i am a trustee
board member of the mid-suffolk citizens
advice
okay item 11.
any more declarations of interest
thank you
can we now go
oh sorry counselor
uh yeah thank you madam chairman um yeah
in relation to councilman i'm only an
observer with the uh
uh sudbury uh citizen's advice but i'd
uh i'd declare that i am a
observer on that thank you thank you
any other
quite
member
declarations of interest
thank you
uh we now need to um
go to the
minutes
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting
of the joint overview and scrutiny
committee held on the 20th of september
2021
are there any
points regarding the accuracy of the
minutes
no
could i have a proposal please counselor
muller a secondary police
councilor carter
the governance officer will now conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair
the vote will now show in pro
show as in progress on your modern.gov
app in a light blue color if members
could please go to the plus sign in the
top right hand corner of their agenda it
will show one there and counselor
phillips could i please take your vote
verbally
thank you
i think robert you're gonna have to take
mine difficult getting in
my vote would be abstaining because i
was not at the last meeting
yeah yeah thank you robert um i have the
same problem uh but i have to abstain on
that one as well
thank you
thank you chair the vote has been um
completed and that's five four one
against and four abstentions
thank you
um
thank you that the minutes of the 22nd
of september have been confirmed and i
will sign the minutes after meeting
thank you
we go on to item 4
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme none received chair thank you
questions by the public
none received chair
i made mistake voting on those minutes
and i voted against instead of staying
um
would it be possible to change that
though uh what we can do if we re-run
the vote um would that be acceptable
chair and just go through it again just
to make sure that that's clear so if i
go
no problem with cancer so what i'll do
is i will restart it again
um so that it's all clear that
everything so if mems could go back to
the mob.gov app it will show again in
progress
council phillips go just confirm your
vote again abstain again thank you
well i've voted but it's not showing up
i think we're having some problems
electronically here
can i just ask councillors if they are
having issues voting to check which
internet connection we are connected to
if the computers have a habit of habit
signing into one or the other and modern
gov is not allowing for voting if it is
into either the o2 um
internet
or two things so make sure it's on the l
wl 35 generic and it will allow for
voting to work on your computer
and what i'll do chairs if i just take
the votes that are remaining as verbally
if that's acceptable yes so council
mclaren if i could take your vote please
stay
and councillor osborne
thank you very much
so
first
sorry chair apologies just getting that
so that is um five four none against and
five abstentions
i think that's correct isn't it
counsellor
thank you
so just to repeat uh the minutes of
meeting have now been confirmed and i
will sign them after the meeting
i think i'd actually reached com
questions by councillors on the agenda
robert have we received any none
received yet thank you
so um
we are now having a presentation at the
review of the shared legal service
and i'm happy to welcome teresa halliday
um theresa if you'd like to give us your
presentation thank you
hi um good morning
committee members
um the report is an overview of the
legal service
it's your in-house legal service
officers within the
um service are employed by either baber
mid-southwark or west suffolk councils
um
the report in front of you
um provides you with details of the
budget allocation
how the management structure
in that
the
service is an in-house service
i'm the service manager
i'm employed by west suffolk but i work
equally across all three councils and
then i report to a steering committee
which
consists of the um director for um law
and governance at west suffolk and emily
ewell who's the assistant director for
law and governance at baber and all four
babur mid suffolk and then we report to
leadership teams
across the three authorities
um
financial performance is we have a case
management system so every matter that
we're instructed on
is opened within that system
the system
has what's called two instances one is a
vapor and mid suffix instance and the
other is a west suffolk instance
currently we don't um separate whether
the report comes from baber or
or the instruction comes from baba or
from mid suffolk
it just comes as a baber mid suffolk
instruction but what we are looking to
do um from the next financial year
is report be um introduce something into
the case management system which enables
us to report those separately
the
cost split is based on when the is
currently based on
the amount of matters that we have the
complexity of those matters
because you can have
five instructions for a simple debt
recovery
for one authority but that will equate
to one more difficult
um
and complex matter that would take
longer to to complete
so we we have a volume
plus complexity
amount of hours it takes against each
matter
and the initial split was based on the
budgets so the budget for the legal
service for west suffolk
and the budget for baber mid suffolk was
put together and the split was based on
the differences between those budgets
because it was a bringing together of
all those staff into that one structure
work we undertake ranges from
a simple debt recovery a commercial
lease to a more complicated
judicial review
or prosecution
an injunction
um but it's fairly even across
all of all the directorates within each
of the authorities
we are instructed in the same way anyone
in the in another services
is provided with a piece of work to do
we receive an email asking if we can
provide legal advice we have a generic
email box to receive those
we don't identify other than putting it
into the case management system whether
we're working for baber mid suffolk or
west suffolk we are just providing a
legal service
so um the the priority comes in is is
looked at
we don't prioritize one authority over
another it's about the work and when the
work needs to be completed
and that that's it really unless
anyone's got any questions
can i put that to a committee now
if you would like to ask questions of
the the officer councillor egg
thank you madam chairman um i have a
couple of uh questions um
i i understand
that
the split of the
budget is basically
an apportionment of budgets that already
existed existed sorry uh rather than on
any other criteria but i do note that in
fact
in
chapter paragraph 3.5
there are more
employees in
on the west suffolk side than there are
on
the baby mid-suffox side
and i wondered to what extent that might
weigh on things
but i'd like to get into the detail of
the graph on
in paragraph 3.10
um
i'd like to get some explanation of
these numbers um
baby sustainable community seems to have
a lot of instructions
way more than anybody else and then
followed by planning for growth
what what is that
and could we have some detail around
the instructions from assets and
investments please
so in terms of your first question
initially um it was bringing together of
two budgets since then we've had the
case management system so for the first
two years budgets were based on the um
two budgets across the authorities three
budgets across the authorities now we
look at the case management system and
the volume of matters coming from each
authority to determine how we're going
how that split is going to be
managed and that's
something for the steering group to
consider when they're presented with
reports
we report to the steering group
quarterly
the next meeting in december is to
review the split for the next financial
year
and
up to date we haven't it hasn't been
necessary to alter that split based on
the volume of work
in terms of the graph sustainable
communities is very high that tends to
be that's commercial leases
um acquisitions
our property team is the large property
and commercial team is the largest team
within the service because the volume of
work is the highest across all three
authorities
because we have a lot of commercial
leases
acquisitions right to buy scheme for
baber midsoffic
planning again is a high volume because
we have three planning committees we
support and provide advice for
does that
help
so answer your question uh
not entirely
um
so
sustainable communities is all to do
with commercial leases and similar
and so i failed to understand why it's
under sustainable communities to be to
be fair
um because you also have a section
that's housing
um as well as you and you've got assets
in investment it just seems
that the descriptive tag doesn't seem to
gel with me
really
i apologize the descriptive tag is the
directorate from which those
instructions are coming there are more
um
descriptions than current directorates
because when each direct whenever
there's a
change uh structure change across the
authorities and they change the name of
a directorate or they move a service
from one directorate to another
we can't alter that all on the case
management system without
taking it straight back to day one so we
create new matters under the new
structure but we may still have open
matters under the old structure so
but i
i can't tell you why those come from
that
director other than that's where the
instructions are coming from
[Music]
i think you may have
contradicted yourself in that response
so the instructions are coming from
sustainable communities
so
my question was what does commercial
leases have to do with sustainable
communities
i'm afraid i'm unable to answer that
question because we're acting from
the instructing officer and which
directorate they're sitting in
um
i i
don't create where that comes from um
i don't know if you want to help emily
emily thank you
thank you chair morning councillors um
so i think there there might be some
confusion around
the term sustainable communities that
was the assistant director area that
encompassed planning and
communities so planning and communities
on this
chart was the former name then it
converted to sustainable communities
now it's actually changed again because
communities has gone in with the
well-being
and communities directorate so
you can see some of the challenges that
teresa's team has every time we make a
management structure change that affects
the case management system and it's
difficult to repair those
or alter those retrospectively
i think some of these commercial leases
come from the section that used to sit
in with the sort of sill team about
acquisitions um in terms of uh
residential properties i think that's
that that's the cases that are referring
to there where it's purely um commercial
properties that of course would sit in
assets and investments if it's our um
our own property or in economic
development
thank you emily does that help you
counseling it's a much clearer
explanation madam chairman but it does
beg the question is what are we going to
do about this system because clearly
it's not keeping pace with
the way that the council is being
organized
except that and of course
in in terms of your comment uh you were
looking at communities as it's seen
within our present makeup
of the say the cabinet and and the
responsibilities so thank you teresa for
clarifying that
thank you
am i right in thinking that the um
they're still doing the same job just
the titles changed
yeah thank you chair um i've got a
series of questions
um can i refer to
um 3.5
and counselor opinion asked about the
the nine offices employed by baber and
mid suffolk
and the 14 employed by
west suffolk
um
my question is around um the the
salaries and the terms of employment
reimbursement of expenses and traveling
and so on
uh this is the first question that is
are the
terms and conditions employment
conditions identical
um
so i saw a shake of heads is that is
that a problem um
i don't i do do you want to take the
questions one at a time yeah
um no the the employees are under their
current authorities working terms and
conditions
and the reason we have
a different volume of staff and pointed
by one authority to another is to
because we have different rates of pay
across west suffolk and weber and mid
suffolk we try to align the job types so
that we don't have two lawyers doing
exactly the same job sitting next to
each other on different rates of pay and
terms conditions so we try to appoint a
lawyer to one authority
a job type to one a particular authority
so we have um
our support team
our
in the majority employed by west suffolk
um our lawyers
babur mid suffolk our business partners
currently west suffolk and so that's so
people in the same job type there's not
that discrepancy about well you know
they're working the same job as me but
they're earning more money
well i think you probably answered what
was going to be my next question and
that is if there is a vacancy or you
reorganize and so you recruit
how do you decide whether it's
west suffolk who recruits or baba
mid-suffolk recruits if it's let's say
let's say it's a a new post into your
family tree
yep we work very closely together uh one
authority would take the lead on the
recruitment
quite often west suffolk takes the lead
on recruitment um simply because that's
our principal place of work for the
whole of the service
um but we work very closely with beirut
suffolk and if we appoint to a
baby or mid suffolk authority then i
speak with my hr business partner and
work with them on the recruitment for
that post
sorry each of your answers is leading me
on to a different question so if it
so you're using west suffolk hr
presumably this service pays
a fee to
west suffolk hr
no right okay
um
now my next question is if more than 50
percent of the work is for baber mid
suffolk district council
why are there fewer staff employed by
babur mid-suffolk district council
it's based on the job type so um
we if if a
west suffolk lawyer who was there from
day one
moves on leaves the authority
we would try to appoint to a baby mid
suffolk post that they're aligned with
the remaining lawyers in that structure
and that's why the shift is the balance
has changed from day one because we've
tried to align the job types rather than
the individual's original place of
employment
um
sorry can i is it okay to carry on i'm
sorry counselor well i'm just a minute
emily wants to
just add to that emily thank you thank
you i just wondered if i could just add
a an extra bit of context to that
arrangement um
when the partnership was created we made
a conscious decision not to transfer all
of the staff to one of the partner
authorities
almost as a way of preserving um each of
the partners interests should the
service ever dissolve so that there
wouldn't be one of the partner
authorities without any legal team
if it was ever decided that we wanted to
uncouple so we made that conscious
decision not to do atp transfer or
similar at that time so that all of the
partner authorities still directly
employed some of their legal experts
how it works in terms of recharging
is the um when we do the kind of total
share of costs we do a quarterly
recharge between the authorities
and baber and mid-suffolk will recharge
west suffolk for the proportion of staff
costs for those people that we directly
employ and vice versa for west suffolk
so it's almost uh irrelevant that um
babe and mid-suffolk have nine directly
and poor employed and west suffolk have
14
because the the costs of all the staff
are shared proportionately in that split
of costs that we operate across the
whole service
thank you
that's led me on to another question i'm
sorry so if you were if we were to
decouple that seems to suggest that
say west suffolk would have all of the
lawyers or all of the business partners
and we'd end up with the support staff
in baby mid suffolk so i guess it's it's
not going to be so
so this is an observation rather than a
question just a little bit concerned
that that
it's fine that all of the lawyers are in
pla employed by the one authority if
that's the case
but they'll have to be some sort of uh
alternative arrangement if there's a
decoupling um
can you just
restrict that to the debate please
thank you yeah sorry i have got one more
question and this is a question
um
with the complicated cases i understand
that all the complicated cases seem to
be more or less costed
at the same level of cost
so
if there is let's say a really
complicated case such as a judicial
review
is there a record of how much time was
spent by staff at various levels
and also um a record of the external
input for each of the complicated cases
and is that part of the recharge
the quarterly review recharge so we
don't recharge per mata where you're
in-house service so our only recharge is
based on salaries and on costs
um
more complex every single matter that
we're instructed on is recorded in our
case management system and officers
record their time spent against each of
those matters
but that's simply to help us with the
understanding of the split
between the authorities we don't charge
individually for every matter we're
instructed on whether it's a simple
matter or a complex matter
but if um if there were if there was a
need for specialist advice
um
or a barrister or
whatever is is that do you
does the
shared legal service employ that that
individual
right if we if we are required to
outsource for any particular reason so
whether that's engaging a barrister to
assist in a complex judicial review
matter
then we would leave the legal service
would lead on the
engagement of that particular council or
advice
but we would work closely with the
instructing officer to ensure they were
happy with that engagement the reason
the shared service leads on that
engagement is because we build
relationships with
barristers and
external firms and so
they're used to contacting us
um but we always work very closely with
the instructing officer
and and they let's say it's a a
barrister they send their bill to the
shared service not to the
correct and that's and it's um
budgeted out of whichever budget was
required to pay for that whether it's a
legal service budget for
another department thank you i'm out of
questions chair
any more questions counselor barrett
thank you very much um
good morning um i wondered um
looking at the data that you provided in
3.10
that's
sort of very
basic data really on just pure numbers
no no analysis whatsoever
um a little bit more on the other
tables do you have
some performance tables on time taken to
resolve matters
yes absolutely these this is simple data
i agree um but we can call off reports
on many aspects of the case management
system um including uh how long a
particular case takes the amount of time
recorded by each officer against a case
um
i'm trying to think about you know it's
mainly hours spent against the amount of
disbursements that have been created or
external costs against a particular
matter is all recorded
and can i just ask what what then you do
you highlight some areas that are of
concern because they matter it's taking
too long to resolve or what actions
absolutely
always look back we work very closely
with other service managers and other
directorates who are sending us a lot of
information or a lot of instructions at
one time so we look through and say you
know why is this taken longer is there
something that we could be more
proactive about up front or is it just
one of those complicated matters that
looks simple to begin with and then
turned into a more complex matter
we have a complexity scoring when a mata
when we're instructed in a new matter
that we give it to say well this could
take
an experienced lawyer
two months to complete from start to
finish
but if that becomes complicated
that complexity scoring can be upgraded
or downgraded if it turns into an easier
matter but they must discuss that with
their line manager before that
complexity is changed
counselor um just um
interested to know then if
in terms of performance pure performance
of that individual member of staff
so
acknowledging some complexity of a
matter if there were it was still not
becoming resolved who
who is responsible then is that in
within your service to
pursue
some improvement in that performance or
is that
down to the in those individual councils
where does that sit
that absolutely sits with me and my
management team my business partners i
call the management team it sits with us
initially if a member of our service
isn't performing then we would look at
that alongside their um
performance reviews
then if there was a concern that there
was a team that wasn't performing i
would take that to my directorate or
assistant director and say there's
definitely a concern in here and you
know it would only go up through the
same in the same way as if somebody in
the planning team wasn't performing or
somebody in the housing team wasn't
performing it would escalate in exactly
the same way
councilor barrett
councillor
thank you madam chairman i'd like to
refer the officer to
the chart are in 3.11
um
so
currently we have
between the two authorities just over
1100
[Music]
current cases um so my question is
is that typical
how has the number of cases flowed from
the previous couple of years into the
current year and and what's the trend
looking like
yep this is a snapshot of the number
taken at the time of the report but it
is um
the the chart at 3 11
is very similar to that for west office
as well uh just a slight variation in
each area but yes the busiest teams are
planning
um and property
commercial slightly less litigation
fluctuates because litigation is very
much based on the number of instructions
they receive whether there is one
prosecution or or 10 it all depends
what's happening across the authorities
as to how busy they are but they also um
support licensing and other regulatory
matters but yes this is a
an average snapshot of how the team is
performing
if i could come back madam chairman so i
understand that this is a snapshot um i
think the
crux of my question is how does this
compare to previous years how many other
numbers going up or they're going down
or
numbers are going up there's an upward
trend um
particularly in the
property team we have a lot more
instructions than we have used to i
think there's also a knock-on effect
from um
the kovid pandemic because mata slowed
down but then they did the um
stamp duty holiday and mata's just
progressed
uh from then really and and it's just a
continuing upward trend
in other areas it fluctuates
counselor
caster
thank you yeah i'm i
just wanted to sort of define am a
matter if um if a file is opened
could there be several matters
on that file or is that what you would
describe as a matter cause obviously
with litigation
there could be a matter of litigation on
a
file that's got
you know for something else yeah could
you define that please each mat each
instruction has its own matter opened on
our case management system unless it's
something that would be dealt with
within half an hour from start to finish
then we put it into a general file
otherwise we'd have hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of matters that
wouldn't show up in any graph because
they'd only have a half hour recorded
against them but yes so um if we have
a
planning judici so a good example is in
the property in commercial teams we
might have a project which involves
giving procurement advice and contract
advice to begin with and then turning
and if it's a property related matter
would turn into
creating a development agreement or a
commercial lease we would open a
different matter for each aspect of that
but they would be
cross-referenced within the case
management system so we if somebody
wants to know that the total time spent
on a particular project we would call
all those in together to give a total
time and be able to break it down into
each individual matter within that
project
is that
answer your question yes perfect very
clear thanks have i got any more
questions
i will ask the my questions now thank
you
um
in terms of
the three point
the table on 3.8 teresa
that
allocates the budgets i think
i found it confusing i understand
what you did
the um
total budget for baba and mid-suffolk
district councils is 613 000
but in your table you've actually
added west suffolk council which
actually the bottom line doesn't add up
i understand why you've done it
can you see that in the table you've put
the three councils together
is that or have i misunderstood that
the two baby i make baby mid suffolk
district council's total six hundred and
thirteen thousand
five
yeah so in fact it should have added in
then shouldn't it i thought
thank you because i thought i was a bit
worried i misunderstood that so thank
you for that
um my other question is really about um
judicial review
and if i refer you to page 30
um
if you're looking at i i understand on
the pla i'm on the planning committee so
i understand the principle of judicial
review can you just clarify and you may
not be able to can you clarify for me
is the judicial review requested
by the applicant
or can it be requested
by
another person
so the applicant would
would appeal against the decision a
judicial review application generally
comes from an interested party
which may not be the applicant the
applicant would go down a different
route they would appeal
it would be um any other interested
party with their only room it would be
judicial review whereas the applicant's
remit is to appeal against the decision
okay so two separate thank you for
clarifying that for me um
sorry just coming quickly at the end
there um
i was going to ask a little bit about
section 106 agreements
yes
nasty nasty section 106s um
[Music]
have you any views on
whether
whether they will
continue and whether or do we have any
influence over whether when they are
used as a as opposed to sill
or
because they seem to take an awfully
long time
so is there do we have any sort of
jurisdiction over that or is it just
that
there will always be
those agreements as well as sil
i'm afraid i can't answer that question
i just don't know the answer to that
question um but what i can say is yes
section 106's can take um some time to
complete
uh a lot of that is outside the control
of the authority or your or your legal
service because there are so many
parties to bring to that one document
including county council and maybe a
developer then maybe the developer's
agent maybe other interested parties at
the highways authority
but i really can't say whether
there's any
change of foot or anything i'm afraid
okay
um
just before we go to debate can i just
remind the committee that it is three
years since this
service was actually reviewed
and then i think in that time
there's been a change certainly in the
membership of this committee
and in the circumstances that surround
our world really that could impact this
service so um you may need to bear that
in mind when we go as we go to debate so
can i open the debate please for members
thank
on that note uh chair i think i was here
three years ago
weirdly
for a brief period on ovue and scrutiny
when we did
take quite present questions and so on
um and oddly enough coming back for this
one so
but but
just to kick off oh thank you councillor
barrett councillor casting
thank you madam chairman
um
this is i found this really interesting
this um process
it's um i can understand um some
councils would like to see more
information in there but um this is an
incredibly complex
way of working out but way of working
out how
which
authorities use in what and i think it
works i think it i think it's very
sensible
and um
it's um it's very fair as well um
one thing when i
looked at this it was um
putting baber and mid suffolk together
for me it was um i thought well
maybe we're not um quite at that stage
yet but it sounds like work's been done
now to separate them which is yeah
which is moving forward for me but um
yeah i think it's a really good report
yes there could be more information
there but i think um we could easily
drown in information when um
there's some
we've got a lot of very useful
information here so um it's
it's really good to have this
the
if we were doing this
outside we had a
um legal firm taking care of this we'd
um we wouldn't have the um wait to um
if we get a judicial review or anything
happens to move those resources around
these councils so i think um resource
wise we're um
this is exactly the right way to be um
running it it's um
it's hard to work out what the workload
of um
different departments is from this but i
think that's why you have managers and
you have people um watching that so um
yeah i
i'm um i've thank thank you for your um
answering the questions and i think it's
a very good report
councillor girls
yes thank you um i was
i was pleased to note that
for example at 3.13
or 3.14 sorry
that there are still some areas that we
can't cope with in-house
because it is such as councillor custom
says it's such a huge subject
so i was comforted to know that when
this is the case we actually do buy in
the external advice and skills that we
need
so that that struck me as as good
because
the page before that on 3.12 i have made
myself a note
that
do we do some kind of skill audit of the
staff
so that the
the skills of the staff reflect the
topics that are being covered so when i
then got down to 3.14 i thought ah that
has answered my question so thank you
councillor
thank you chair i wonder if i could ask
a question
um i know we're in debate but just
something which has um
come to mind and going back to i i was
actually employed once upon a time many
years ago and one of the one of the
concerns there about external services
which are just sort of a little shift
away from the actual authority
was around the quality of the
instructions that were given
um particularly in the early days so i
wonder if you could each give me just a
a flavor of whether the quality of the
instruction by the instructing officer
to the shared legal service is improving
has reached a stage where it is
satisfactory um or whether there is
still room for room for improvement but
i guess also that
these sorts of if there are these sorts
of problems that they would be discussed
at your quarterly meetings
yes
it's a constant improvement we're on a
constant route to improvement we're
never perfect we recognize that so we're
in constant dialogue with our
instructing officers about instructions
um from day one to now we've created
instruction pro formas which i reviewed
which
allows the instructing officer to
understand what information we need to
enable to do the the piece of work they
want us to do for them we have regular
meetings and workshops with instructing
teams to make sure the quality of the
instructions um create a quality of work
at the end of the day
um
what was the second part of your
question so i think that was that was i
was really sort of asking if um if emily
was uh was aware of any need for
improvement or whether they're
when when new staff
come along to the two districts i guess
they they they need to be trained in how
to instruct the shared legal service i
just wanted to know that that was all
working smoothly because that interface
can cause difficulties in some
authorities i have experienced in the
past many years ago
thank you emily
thank you chair um yeah just to add to
teresa's um response i actually think
this is one of the real success stories
of the shared legal service um the
quality of instructions i think is
dramatically improved um to when the the
service was first set up because i think
people had the bad habit of just
wandering down the corridor and going
and talking to the lawyer and thinking
that was sufficient to to give them an
instruction what we now have is a really
clear document that sets out
what the instruction officer wants to
achieve from that piece of legal advice
or that activity and it enables then
teresa to go back and evaluate whether
that outcome was actually achieved by
the team or not so it's also a mechanism
for sort of performance management and
quality control so
from my perspective that that's a real
um success story and i think in
a high percentage of cases we have very
good instructions and there's always um
a few people that we um just help a
little bit with with completing the form
in the right way but it's it's a much
better um situation when when it was
first created in in 2016. thank you um i
wonder is uh attendance at say planning
committee
um
a significant part of the workload of
certain members of staff i'm i'm aware
that
there are certain members of staff who
regularly attend is that a significant
part of the work though because and you
know is that is that one instruction for
that will last for the
year or one instruction for each meeting
we don't class attendance at meetings
and instruction that's just part of our
role we're a legal support service
but we have we try to have a
continuation of service for members so
that members recognize the legal advisor
at their particular committee meeting
so you may have a particular officer
attend um a babe or a mid-suffolk
committee meeting and a different
officer attend a west suffolk simply so
the members get to know them but um they
can swap about if necessary so zombies
are ill somebody else can step in
um counselor
we did have a period of time for
questions
sorry we did have a time for questions
yeah yeah this is the debating part of
the meeting
um
right so
i'm just wondering yeah i mean thank you
very much for the report and the
answering the questions
i just feel that because we have
uh a number of uh
joint initiatives the two districts and
i understand from
the the officers that
there's going to be a split between
um
presently
the charge goes to baba mid-suffolk or
to west suffolk then it's split
now it's going to be split so that that
that will be split at the time of
instruction i just wonder whether
because there are so many joint
initiatives whether there ought to
also be um a cost center around the the
the joint initiatives because otherwise
they've got to be split in the added
together split and and so on i just
wonder if that can be if we can find a
way of tidying that up are you
suggesting that goes into some sort of
recommendation counselor well i i i i
think i think so yeah i think that can
we just continue with the debate if the
commitment you very much sorry you were
just about to go um i'd
i'd like to see more
um performance stats
if this were to come back and i
appreciate it's three years time it's
it's a long lead in time but um perhaps
in our recommendations we could include
that
so that is picked up because
looking at the that we don't need to
understand that the department is busy i
think we all appreciate that um
appreciate they've got a large volume of
matters and instructions
but looking at those figures they only
tell half the story
um
those some of those matters may have
been on their list for a long time
waiting to be resolved i i know of two
cases that i've been dealing with and
they are
taking taken some time some consider one
one considerable amount of time um and i
think that is a a subject that we as
councillors should be aware of if
matters are just not seem to be
progressing at a satisfactory rate at
least to seek seek an explanation so i
think that's what we we would need
um
so i'd like to see that in some
recommendations
thank you
are there any other committee members
with
councillor pino
thank you madam chairman i think
councillor barrett's actually picked up
on a point i wanted to highlight um
because i think while the data that's
been provided
at a cursory glance is useful it's not
as meaningful as it possibly could be in
in my view
um
it's not clear to me really
how the different types of work are
dispersed within this shared legal
service and i appreciate that it's a
very good service
as has been mentioned
and i think we need to see information
that really passes this in terms of how
the council is certainly babel and
mid-suffolk are organized for it to
really have significant meaning for us
uh and allow us to investigate it more
in a more meaningful way um
and so i in addition to to the
performance issue that counselor barrett
has raised i'm also keen to understand
the the the
split of work between
the different uh
sections of the council as we understand
it now i i'd also like to understand um
especially with regard to the chart in
3.11
what has been the trend there
irrespective of the situation caused by
the pandemic um because i think it's
important to understand the direction of
travel these different elements and how
that could impossibly or potentially
impact the
um the resources of the shared legal
service uh
going forward so i think there are
elements here that still need
to be addressed and i think that
should be
encompassed in the recommendation
because
i'm not really able to make
significant meaningful determinations
from the data provided today
uh thank you um i'd like to say this is
a very detailed and thorough report
which is
it is helpful
but reading it and some of the answers
i've it has given me some concerns when
reading it it is clear that we are
currently set up in a way that is
um
protective if we should split
which
way i see that gives a bit of a
we're also working as well at different
paid levels for different build a
different
set of different councils but we're
doing a joint service
and while i read if i was working for
that i'd be concerned about a bit of job
security
because you're set up in a way that if
we are likely to split we're protecting
the councils we're set up in a way where
you can be doing the same job as
somebody
but
get different pay grade if we have been
so we are
united but divided and we've got
additional way of doing payback
four different workloads
which are surely causing more of a hr
thing which causing us more
financials and way with more work in
making sure that this is working
than if we had a united front or if i
had a single pay level if we had a
more interconnectivity
so we're either
covering ourselves by having a joint one
by but not being joined an additional
overweight
or
it to me it's there'd be kind of a
if i was working in that environment i'd
be a little concerned about what our
futures would hold are we splitting are
we not and is it
is it fair for people working for us
where we could have been employed
next door and get more money would are
we going to look to jump to one council
to the other for the same job
um
i also have the concern with a
the way
i know it's
changes we've implemented
that have changed to the different
titles
coming down to which you know
the officer coming down saying this is
going underneath
one title and it's going on
surely
sure
there could be a degree of human error
during that way having these
simultaneous
current open and current open
titles going down to the officers could
there be a mistake of being put into
for underneath the wrong heading keeping
that heading going when it's not
necessarily needed without hidden any
further could there be any issue
could there be any confusion as to what
inbox it eventually ends up on
it's a bit
it's
i know it can't be back channeled you
can't
move it over but surely that's going to
have
some additional
strain with human error
and i'm afraid there is a question mixed
up in there because it was a question
that's been raised by um counselor when
i hadn't occurred beforehand
but if
it hadn't occurred to me about officers
having to attend meetings as additional
part of a no it's part of a workload
are
all meetings in the same building for
all for all the councils
um if so are all officers having to do
the same amount of journeys to these
meetings
is like a planning officer having to
travel to
solely to endeavor house to do the
meetings or are there other
[Music]
other officers they have to travel to is
that reflected in the extra journey
times extra
workloads is um is it all very reflected
into the
um
well into the account of a
workload is reflected to is the same
officer having to do all the mid-south
west suffolk or is there different to
planning officers that we'll do for west
africa
how is that working out and how is that
um affecting these officers is there
additional strain for them
so how's that recognized
can i just ask um
emily do you feel
happy to respond to those concerns
raised by councillor carter thank you
thank you chair and i will probably
bring teresa in in terms of the um
deployment of staff to different
activities just to talk about um how
staff are assigned to different roles
and and what that means in terms of
journey times and and that sort of thing
um
so just for a point of clarification no
legal officer is paid differently for
work at the same level so all of the
lawyers are on the same pay scale
all of the legal assistants are on the
same pay scale all of the legal business
partners are on the same pay scale so
they are on different pay scales because
each authority has a different pay scale
but within a single job role nobody is
paid different so there is no unfairness
in terms of being paid differently for
the same work so just to provide you
with that reassurance
we have considered transferring all of
the staff
over to a single employer to have that
consistency of terms and conditions and
we haven't made that decision at the
moment we didn't feel like the
disruption of being transferred in into
a different employer was was
appropriate at the time but it is
something that the legal services
steering board would keep under review
um but i just want to really reassure
you that no member of staff is
disadvantaged by virtue of their
employing authority
and there's there's no case of kind of
sitting next to somebody who's being
paid more for the same level of work uh
we we work really hard to make sure that
that doesn't happen um and just on the
directorate label
really that's um
a label that we give to the matter
within the case management system it
doesn't have any bearing on the team
that the work is allocated to so there's
no danger of the work being misallocated
and so you know the the property team
wouldn't end up with a license in mata
for example because um of that goes for
a filter with the admin team and they
make sure that the cases are properly
allocated when they come in
theresa did you want to talk about um
the the staff kind of location of where
yep so um we don't look at
people in my team um
i don't i i forget who's there they're
employing authority because we just look
at ourselves as a as a team
working across three authorities
in terms of
how we select who would attend
let's say development control committee
for baber
we would
select one of our planning lawyers
our lawyers are all employed by baber
mid suffolk
and some of them live very locally so
they'll probably pick the most local
person to reduce that travel time
for them
but equally they would travel i've
traveled
here today from various and edmonds to
attend here but um that's just because
that's where i live it doesn't it and
i'm the service manager it has to be
here
if i lived in ipswich it would be
exactly the same i would still be
attending here it's not we don't select
the location to the officer
does that answer your question
is that helpful counselor carter
certainly is
does raise the point however
with he travelling in with officers is
it mandatory for them to be in
physically in the meeting or could it be
done remotely
um
in a right attendance with uh
teams for them to
still be there to answer the questions
but without having to journey time
would it be a benefit to them
at the moment we don't have hybrid
meetings across the authorities but
there's certainly that's been looked
into
um at the moment it's required that the
legal advisor is in attendance along
with the committee for those regulatory
committees other meetings we would
appear remotely and we're
95 of the time working from home as a
team at the moment
okay
i think
if members are agreed i think we've had
a good debate on this
um
and
i'd like us to
consider the record this this report is
for noting only
but we are
we are requested
uh or if we're minded to add some
recommendations and and members of race
different things that they they feel
councillor wallam shall we start with
yeah sorry i was just going to add sure
i believe i've captured two members um
what they thought so i didn't catch
councillor wellam so i was just going to
ask if councilwoman could just repeat
what
his possible recommendation was and then
i can read out that yes okay that's fine
thank you
sure yeah i'm i'm i'm quite happy to to
go back
and repeat what i said but i'm i'm just
a little bit concerned that it's almost
like micromanaging them and i just
wondered if the officers would say that
it's something that they would look at
rather than we actually have to put it
into a recommendation if we had to put
it in a recommendation then i would say
something like this we know that the
shared legal service is setting up
separate cost centers for each of our
two sovereign authorities and we ask
that as much of the activity of the two
authorities involves joint initiatives
and actions and appropriate costs sent
to be set up now
rather than if i could have a couple of
nods from the left then i don't think it
needs it needs to be a recommendation
thank you chair um i have just jotted
down a um proposed recommendation that
the committee might like to adopt albeit
i probably have a declaration of
interest given that the recommendation
will come my way to to action so
if i just uh read that out chair and
then the committee can can decide
whether that reflects your discussion um
so um the recommendation would be that
the legal services steering board
reviews the recharging mechanism for the
costs of the legal service
and considers whether the performance
monitoring arrangements are sufficient
the decisions of the legal services
steering board will be will be presented
back to the committee via an information
bulletin after its meeting in december
chair that that covers my point i i
don't know whether it satisfies
counsellor epping young and barrett
council
thank you madam chairman i i i i'm happy
with that particular element of
recommendation but i think we probably
need a second recommendation which can
come back at a future report which is to
look at the the trend of the performance
in terms of the different elements of of
litigation property and so forth
because i think the the charts
themselves in the in the current report
are a snapshot as as
the service manager pointed out and and
what i would be keen to see is what is
the trend of this of these data data
points so at the next reporting
opportunity then i think that's what we
should be recommending to see
thank you
um council muller
yes i'm perfectly happy with emily's
proposal for one of the recommendations
but i totally agree with what kate sure
evan youngman obviously counts for
barrow to mention that we do need
another recommendation regarding
performance etc thank you
yes councillor barrett can i just check
that the
wording that emily has just proposed on
did you say uh
consider whether performance
stats are sufficient
so is that for your department to
consider
right
it's i i feel what we want is to just
definitely see more performance targets
in that report so
i don't know you could that would be the
second recommendation yeah yeah as long
as that is absolutely coming back to
this committee because it sounds like
you already gathered those stats in a
way so
it's just a matter of us being able to
to understand them better
i would like to see that sheriff if i
may i think the um performance trends
could be reported back in the
information bulletin so that you would
see it
fairly
soon after this meeting rather than
waiting for another sort of periodic
review of the service
and you're absolutely right council
about we do
we do collate performance management
data and we do
feed in through the cabinets monitoring
of performance across the organization
so
it should be fairly easy for us to
present that information to you
sorry i don't put me i can't counsel
councillor carter
thank you
i had to wonder as we are making if we
are making recommendation could we put
in there about looking into the hybrid
meetings of
officer attendance surely it's a matter
of the semantics of whether or not
they're physically in a room of a
meeting or ever attending with that
additional technology would it not be
beneficial to actually look further into
putting in these with it because it
would reduce journey time for you for
offices and we could still have a
functioning uh a meeting with members in
attendance and officers being virtually
in attendance
emily thank you
thank you chair yeah um as um teresa has
mentioned at the moment it is a legal
requirement for any officer who is
advising the committee
um to be present in the meeting room in
much the same way that attendance means
in person for
members
but i entirely agree with you councillor
carter we've demonstrated during the
pandemic that we can operate effectively
and lawfully and actually more
accessibly during um by having virtual
meetings um so you know we are always
looking for opportunities to lobby to
for a return to hybrid or virtual or
even just to have the ability to choose
for ourselves as an authority how we
want to hold meetings and i note that
north norfolk council has just recently
lobbied
the government on a return to
virtual meetings so that may be
something that our councils would want
to
think about perhaps by way of a to full
council
yeah counselloracy neil uh thank you
about it just a question for emily
in her
comment about bringing forth information
that with the information bulletin would
that include um
some historical data about
that i'm asking for so we can see the
trends
yes absolutely we'd bring the
performance trend data
in into that information bulletin so you
can see the journey um over
a period of time
can i
can i just ask the question of the
committee
as i said at the outset that it's three
years since this was reviewed
do we feel that is the
period of time
that we need to review this service or
do we need to review that
it's three years
too much or too little
counseling
i think three years is quite a
reasonable time but um what we were
saying previously i'd like to perhaps
add to that uh the plan is obviously to
split baba and mid-suffolk in the
statistics
from the new financial year starting in
april 22
and although i agree with emily we can
have an information bulletin of the
various um figures etcetera fairly
recently for our next meeting i think it
would also be helpful to have one
perhaps six months
after the split
in sort of just under 12 months time as
well thank you
other committee agreed with that
sounds reasonable
so yeah i might need a couple of minutes
just to discuss with the monitoring
officer just to get the wording right so
all elements have been covered if that's
okay chair
um to take a short break if that's so we
want a shot before we actually
yeah so that i can get all the way so
members can be can
can be confirmed in the world committee
i think we'll have a short break of how
many minutes
10 minutes that'd be more than enough
yeah so
laurel's born yeah thank you madam
chairman yeah may i just echo the um
recommendations that have been put
forward i i thoroughly agree with them
and particularly with the councillor
muller here um
i would just like to thank teresa and
emily for their excellent report and the
excellent way that they've responded to
the questions that were asked they were
quite considerable and you had to
wasn't like going through trouble but
you you did it well thank you thank you
yes before we go to the break i'd like
to just say that because we might not
get the chance when we come back teresa
thank you so much for you you put a lot
of hard work into the report and for
emily who's been
you know very supportive of all the
questions and the queries that we've
raised so if we just close the session
at the moment and come back in 10
minutes thank you very much
sessions closed doesn't matter i was
going to ask it whether or not for you
committee members can i call us to order
again
and we're continuing
uh where we were before the break
and so i'll ask the governance officers
to organize the recommendations and read
them to the committee thank you
thank you chair so i believe the
monetary authority will read them out
and then the motion that will be in the
that is in
the uh mondoca vote
will be that the committee uh note the
contents of the report and presentation
to the overview sorry that the contents
of the report and the other the
presentation to the overview and
scrutiny committee be noted and that the
committee approved the recommendations
as read out by the monitoring officer
which will follow now if that's a great
coach yeah
thank you chair uh so recommendation one
is that the legal services steering
board reviews the recharging mechanism
for the costs of the legal service and
considers whether the performance
monitoring arrangements are sufficient
the findings of the legal services board
will be presented back to the overview
and scrutiny committee via an
information bulletin after its meeting
in december
recommendation two will be that the
information bulletin in recommendation
one also includes historical and current
performance monitoring data which will
enable the committee to observe the
trends in performance over time
and then recommendation three will be
that a further information bulletin is
presented to the committee six months
into the new financial year
demonstrating the split of new matters
between baba and mid suffolk thank you
chair
thank you emily
are the committee happy with those
recommendations
uh could i have a proposal please thank
you
councillor pinyoung and seconded by
councillor carter
the
governance officer will now
conduct the electoral vote
thank you chair
the vote is now in progress
um
council phillips can i take your vote
verbally please
four thank you
thank you yes yes counselor sorry thank
you chair that's all votes now been
received and that is a unanimous vote
for the proposal
thank you
shall we go on to item 10
and
this is the
jos
stroke 21 stroke 14 task and finish
group for scoping of transport in the
districts
and i want to ask
councillor walama hippie will introduce
the item thank you councillor
thank you chair
yes the task and finish group was set up
following the resolution of joint
overview and scrutiny committee on the
19th of july
its purpose was to consider whether or
not to fully scope a review of the
provision of public transport in rural
areas
the group heard from a number of
witnesses including officers of the
county council and our district councils
and also from the service managers of
community transport providers in mid in
baby and mid suffolk
the main points covered in the
presentations and the responses to
questions from members of the task and
finish group are given on pages 36 and
37 of our papers
it became clear that most residents of
the districts have little knowledge of
connecting communities and there is very
little promotion of the services they
provide
the providers operate under contracts
from scc
the contracts run from around five to
eight years
the breadth of service provided each of
the two districts vary significantly
the group believes that connecting
communities provides vital services to
residents who are aware of what is
available however there are other
providers including volunteer groups
provision of rural transport would
benefit from joined up working and
promotion of all available services and
how to access them
the county council have submitted a bus
service improvement plan for 2022-23
and this will be updated for 23.24
scc will be working with bus companies
to agree enhance partnership
arrangements
it's timely to scrutinize the way
connecting communities and other
transport services are provided in our
districts
our findings will help inform the
preparation of the enhanced partnership
and the 2023-24 bus service improvement
plan
the recommendation to members of this
committee from the task and finish group
are set is set out
on page 38.
if members agree the recommendation the
task and finish group could be invited
to continue their work firstly to scope
a
review and then to carry out that review
and report back
so chair i'd like to um to move the
recommendation
that we carry out a full scoping
exercise but not that we carry out that
exercise today but that it is uh given
to the the task and finish group for
them to continue their work
thank you councillor
um
i would like to take questions um
we can debate but i'd rather keep the
questions on the debate separate
otherwise we might get a bit
confused so can i ask any members i've
got any questions
for councillor willem
councillor osborne
yeah thank you madam chairman i i agree
with uh absolutely with the uh
introduction that council willem has
done
um
i have said that um
it's a question of actually
positioning uh
suffolk county council
with the bus operators to get something
done because
uh
you know so i would say
uh how are you going to how are we going
to attempt to get this
format betterly organized better
organized i should say
so
um
by by all means i you know i
i find it very difficult to uh
to
when you when you have a plan in
applications where they talk about
transport and nothing ever gets done
thank you
can you answer that question
was was there a question now
i think
i i it sounded like a a message of
support and i wondered whether councilor
osborne was actually seconding the um
the recommendation that i put forward
um
so if there is a specific question can i
sorry i
i was listening so intently
hi mate madam cheering
yes um
yes my real question is it's the
position of suffolk county council with
the bus operators and do you believe
that you'll be able to get some
coherent uh agreement
uh with what's not going on at the
moment
yeah thank you thank you um
well the enhanced partnership and the
bus service improvement plan
will will not just be in terms of the
service operators
the bus service operators the bus
companies with their their scheduled
services
what i think
we need to provide to
the group that's working on the bus
service improvement plan
is
the information that they need to to
ensure that the gaps are filled in
connecting communities i think are
contracted to the county to fill those
gaps
i think we've
we realized that they're not doing it as
as efficiently as they might and they're
not aware of everything that's going on
but somebody needs to bring this all
together so the bus services are the bus
services and all of the gaps where there
are no bus services
those are filled uh
in a coherent fashion and advertised
if i may madam chance to
you know just like to thank councilwoman
for that and i'm yeah very much prepared
two seconds your proposal
have any more questions from
councillor wallam
right we'll go straight into debate
the members wish to debate this
subject
counselor barrett
thank you jim um i just think uh this
focus needs to be very clear
in what it's hoping that it will achieve
i mean is it about communication better
communication about the transport
service that exists
but but to highlight where there are
gaps
uh
in need um
i could understand that
you know in terms of our role within
this um if it goes much wider than that
then i think it's in danger of failing
because um you're a small committee and
i don't quite understand how you can
um
uh
achieve anything wider than that
yes
yeah thank you chair yeah i mean i
totally agree
but um i would say that i don't think
we've got to find every gap i think
we've got to show to the county council
that there are gaps and they've got to
find them and they've got to fill them
it's not
up to us to say such in such a village
needs a bus
for market day in the nearest town we
just have to point out that there are
gaps
um and there are providers and those
gaps can be filled with better
coordination and it's down to the county
council to do that coordination
does that reassure you councillor
barrett
um
yes i mean what what also time scales
can can counselor
advisors about
when that work might be
completed
well i think if if
it depends whether it's given to the
task and finish group to do or whether
it's going to keep coming back to this
full joint committee because which will
obviously take much longer i think the
task and finish group can get on with it
reasonably quickly and
um
i i would say that
probably around february march we ought
to be coming back to this committee with
a recommendation of what we need to
report
on to
well
primarily onto onto offices at suffolk
county council
so
yes okay thank you
council carter
thank you
um
just to um reassure everyone here we
have already checked with officers what
our role is to scrutinize and we have
got
a veremer to scrutinize members or
partner organizations and members that
operate within our communities
so
we may not have the
overall say to be able to change
anything ourselves but is are
not just our right but for our
constituents we have a duty to highlight
areas that are failing within the
community that can be improved upon
and do whatever we can to bring
attention to it and to
make other councils aware or are like
organizations aware
we know there's an issue they need to
know an issue and they need to get it
sorted so it's our role as a council to
light a fire up the backsides in the way
to put it nicely to say that they if
they need to get something done and we
need to just get this done
as a for our constituents so whether or
not we have the power to
ultimately change something we've got
the power to bring attention to it to
bring media to it and we have a
responsibility to do this
so scrutiny is ultimately the right
place to do it and if it hadn't already
been said the seconded
well i'm third in it
so
so quite got the counselor
but okay
thank you yeah now i do share um
councillor barrett's concerns because um
when i go through this it sort of dips
in and out
of suffolk county council
business i don't i want i don't want the
scrutiny committee to do anything
that they don't add value to and i think
we've got to be
very careful
where we're going with this whether
we're
going for an authority that is
doing is organizing the bus services and
dealing with that as an authority that
doesn't have any remit on this i was um
the original scope for this for me was
what can
mid-african baber do to improve
transport links and i think a lot of
this has got
um
a little bit um
too obsessed with um
suffolk county council and things that
um they're
dealing with and they're managing the um
we've
got a hundred thousand pounds in like
the
uh in the last budget
going to um sustainable transport in
this area we we need to be looking at
what we can do what mid-suffolk and
baber have control over and what we can
change and i think um
telling suffolk county council what
they're doing wrong
is going to be a waste of the committees
or any work groups time
so um
i'm just concerned at how we go through
here and there's there's several things
that i really do agree with but there's
certain things that i think
that's not really what i was expecting
this work group to um do
thank you counsellor casting before we
go on to anybody else can i just only
can i have your advice on this
are we
working outside of our remit as a
scrutiny committee thank you
thank you chair and no you're absolutely
not working outside of your remit
the overview and scrutiny committee is
able to look into anything that is of
interest to residents in our two
districts and so you do have quite
a wide remit you are able to scrutinize
the other work of the work of other
public authorities
um
who operate within the two districts so
you can look at services provided by
other councils
but unlike certain statutory functions
the other council doesn't have to
respond or doesn't have to comply with
the request to come to a meeting to to
answer questions um so it's a it's on a
very much a collaborative basis and
therefore i would um suggest that
councillor casten's points about making
sure that you approach it in the right
way and it's not seen as just a
criticism of services that are provided
but you know an exercise with a real
genuine interest in improving um the
arrangements for your residents that's
the right way to go so it's about being
constructive in that scrutiny exercise
with with any of those external partners
thank you
custom does that answer your question
yeah just to come back on that i just
when
i've heard language like failed
and
that
that that kind of language used in this
meeting already and i just
i don't think i don't want this to turn
into
some the headline that the scrutiny
committee is trying to put against
another authority that are
doing a um
you know doing a um
the proper job
on certain surf you know
the proper procedure and um dealing with
things and it does concern me that this
is turning into something that the
scrutiny a
non-political entity should be very
careful then proceed with caution
counselor casting
um
councillor pino
thank you madam german um
well
i understand uh counselor customs
reservations
um
but as has been pointed out uh this
overview
and scrutiny committee
does have the remit to look at any
aspect of of life that affects our
residents um
and and this is definitely one of them
uh and it it's an issue
um
right across many different aspects of
of concern
um you know the sustainable uh
sustainability issue there is the the
fact that
we thought uh at the prior meeting that
the the services that were on offer
weren't very well communicated
and of course we do recognize that there
are gaps in the service and and maybe we
may have suggestions as to how those
gaps might be by by might be filled and
obviously it's up to
suffolk county council how they whether
they take that on board and what they do
with it but
it seems to me that
that there's nothing wrong at all with
us highlighting the issues that our
residents feel with regards to transport
and it is an important issue
um and that we bring that to the
attention of the county council as the
overriding authority on transport and
and hopefully they will do something
about it um
and and you yourself were very keen to
to see what they could do in terms of
advertising the services um and indeed
what we were going to be doing in order
to have a more cohesive and
comprehensive network that
not only service the communities that we
represent but actually that did that in
a sustainable way so i i believe that if
we stick to that
which more or less
the recommendation does then i think we
will be able to add value in providing a
steer to the county council about
what our residents want
thank you madam chairman um
yay
my my my feeling is that
and clarification would be handy here um
councilwom
is that in the past where we've had
voluntary services uh by services that
could go to
existing bus stops
we were told quite categorically that
the
two bus companies that were operating on
these bus bus stops would not allow
because of licensing i believe that they
are licensed to their to those bus
companies and therefore if there was
more
more movement in the way that uh those
bus stops could be used by other
voluntary organizations such as
an old quote go start
in sudbury then perhaps it would
it would help the whole of the transport
uh
situation thank you thank you council
osborne councillor
yes um yes chair i agree with uh
councillor osborne but i i don't think i
don't think our role is to solve the
problems i think our role is to identify
where the problems are and to identify
where the opportunities are um
by way of finding out what is being
provided
why it's not being used but then uh not
to try to change the bus services in any
way the the county council has got to
change the way
the way that the services are provided
in terms of your big red buses and so on
but what we what we need to do i think
is to highlight where the gaps are in
those services and the district council
is a consultant on the bus service
improvement plan
and what better way to be
to give that information back to the
county than via the overview and
scrutiny committee
otherwise it would be left to officers
who
you know have got enough to do i think
we can we can we can really add value by
by informing our officers
of what needs to go back to the county
by way of uh responsible consultation
thank you councillor i've got to say as
chairman um
you don't get the opportunity really to
make a comment
um and i would like to just make a
comment on that i was on the task and
finish group
and one of the things
that i found was that
my my residents didn't know anything
about the community connection service
and i think councillor ek pinyong and i
were in the same position on that group
that little was known about what was
especially for areas like shotley
peninsula in which i'm a ward member
and when i asked the question and i did
speak to
the person the lady responsible after
our meeting
and i asked what advertising and
publicity was about their service of
community connections
and she said that
there's not been anything since 2016.
so i think that we have got an
opportunity
to pursue that
so
are we ready to make recommendations
committee
or councillor gold did you
if i may um so we have the resolution
that was put forward by councilwoman
seconded by councillor osborne i'll just
read it out for clarity's sake so that
everyone is aware and that the joint
overview and scrutiny committee resolved
the task and finish group undertake a
full scoping exercise on transport in
the districts is that acceptable to the
proposer and second
yeah
yes yeah that's that's very wide-ranging
i think i think that the task and finish
group will take away from this meeting
how that needs to be narrowed down so
yeah i'm i'm i'm content with that
proposal
counselor phillips
seconder councillor carter uh sorry said
we have a proposal from council of
wellington
osborne seconded
oh sorry my mistake
yeah well to the fourth
sorry i'm chairman is this in in
addition or in replacement of the
the resolution that was at the bottom of
the paper we received
this so that this is the one that the
committee today will be making that was
the resolution of the task and finished
group that it come back to this
committee to then decide whether to be
scoped out if that makes sense so that
was the resolution of the previous yeah
it was the resolution of the task and
finished group and this is the one
decision for today to then go and fully
scope out
after the meeting in the task and finish
group
yeah okay
so the the committee that the joint
overview and scrutiny committee resolve
that the task and finish group undertake
a full scoping exercise on transport in
the districts
chair that's only taking one step i
think i think we want the task and
finish group to actually carry out the
scoping exercise and carry out the
exercise not just come back here in a
couple of months time having scoped it
we want them to do it
to scope and carry out
a review of
or whatever the work the other words
were
i mean it seems to me madam chairman the
preamble ought to be
the the
what council william said which is uh to
instruct
for this committee to instruct the tax
and finish group directly do what was
said in our resolution which is review
the effectiveness blah blah blah blah i
mean i think
that would cover everything i think i
think and then actually
focus us on what we
intended to do
chair i think the discussion is whether
the whole committee undertakes the
review or whether you want to delegate
it to the um
working group am i right
yes
yeah i think my concern with what um the
governance officer read out was that
he referred to the scoping exercise not
to the exercise um we need to carry out
the exercise not just to scope it and
then come back
so
i i don't think there's anyone here who
believes that the whole committee should
carry out the exercise so it is an
instruction to the task and finish group
and i think the instructions for the
task and finish group is to do it
not to scope it yeah
well both but but obviously
we do we don't we don't
i don't believe that we should be
reporting back to this committee with
just the scoping done we need to get on
and do it
no okay can i just say as chair
councillor wallam i agree with you i'm
not sure what
robert
i think we need to just reword that
yeah i i have reworded it in like what
members have just said so this is more
acceptable as well um so i have got that
the
have you have you just redone that then
i i haven't confirmed it
so let's let's just um
so i've reworded the joint overview and
scrutiny committee resolved that the
task and finish group scope and carry
out the exercise
as it comes under that point so
acceptable sorry emily wants to come and
share with that
emily
thank you
of course the committee can delegate
both of those activities to the working
group my only concern is that
the working groups findings will be
reported back to the full committee
before any decision is made so if the
committee hasn't been involved in either
deciding the scope or signing off the
scope
you may find that the working group
presents you with information that
doesn't fulfill your needs in terms of
making a decision as a committee
so it's
it's just are you comfortable with the
working group setting its own framework
for the work that it will undertake
councillor phillips
i think that's going to be down to a
question of trust in in the individuals
working on that particular task
counselor barrett
i think i would prefer to see the
scoping exercise come back to committee
because i am possibly a little bit
uncertain about the
uh whether i would support uh
um
the the the work that of this uh task
and finish group so i would want to
have some input into
how wide
a study that was going to be before
before it goes too much further
councillor welland do you want to
respond to council about
now i don't i i don't i don't see the
need to come to come back with the with
the scoping down before we start because
that will just delay everything by a
month i think we need to get on and we
need to get on and do it
if if we don't get it done
until after
the um
the county have consulted the district
on
on the next bus service improvement plan
we'll miss the boat the sooner we start
the better
apart from councillor barrett are there
any other
committee members that
support what she's saying
yes i i do actually um
sorry about this counselor well
um i think i'm not i think we need to
come back you're saying that we want to
just get on with it but i'm not sure
that i know what it is
until the scoping comes back to this
were you committee to contribute to that
yeah no i'm in agreement with that
counselor
can we not just put it to the vote and
let them
decide whether they go forwards with
that and then if it if it fails
then perhaps try another reword
okay
shall we go to a show of hands
that it either goes
to the full exercise we leave it to the
task and finish to go oh
they scope the task and finish group
scope the exercise
and
come back to this committee with a
report
so um
how are we going to do that
emily
thank you chair you have got a um motion
on the table with a proposer and a
seconder so it would be appropriate to
take the vote on the recommendation that
the governance officer read out if that
fails then the committee can look at an
alternative recommendation
robert it's up to you though
thank you chair um so i have that in the
um in mob.gov so i it as it reads as it
was before in the sense that so it reads
that the joint overview and scrutiny
committee resolved that that the task
and finish group scope and carry out the
exercise
so that's currently what it is and if
the vote will start
now on that councillor phillips is going
to take your vote please four thank you
thank you chair
all votes now been received and that is
seven votes four and three again so that
is carried
thank you committee
chair before we move on to the next one
could i please um have two seconds to
get our guests into the chat absolutely
can we just uh a five minute break while
our
guests come and accommodate themselves
at the end of the
chamber
are you okay counselor as well
are you
yeah
can i call the committee to order
so i want to continue with the agenda
which is item 11
and it's jos stroke 21 stroke 15
scoping of citizens advice review and
i'm going to ask councillor welland to
present the
paper thank you
thank you chair this would have been
counselor scarf but he's unable to
attend today
so
just a very very brief introduction
by way of
referral back to two years ago when
a task and finish group of this
committee was set up to
review the citizens advice service
across the whole of suffolk it was a
joint review
to which
other district councils and the county
council were invited
west suffolk provided representative
representatives and so did ipswich
and so we had a review of the service
across the whole of suffolk
we reported back i was part of that task
of finnish group we
reported back
our joint uh joint over scrutiny
committee accepted the findings of the
task and finished group and have
subsequently agreed to review the
service
annually
not the whole service
because obviously we did that two years
ago but really to look at any current
and recent impacts on service provision
and how we might be able to um
facilitate change how we can add value
rather than to look at everything that
they do
and question them on every aspect of
their work so it's really
it would really be to
to to to look to look at recent impacts
on their service
thank you councillor
i'd like to welcome to the meeting
vicki mosley corporate manager for
communities and royston emerson as
communities officer
and i think following on your
presentation just now i would like to
give them the opportunity to make some
comments
on um
helping us
to
review the citizens advice
services
so over to you vicky
uh thank you chair um yeah i think every
year the over joint reviews scrutiny
committee reviews um the the impact and
the work that the device undertakes on
like say on an annual basis and i
believe that the
stone market and also sudbury and
district uh citizens advice being
invited to your meeting in december to
provide presentations on the work that
they've completed over the last year
what we would like to try and do and we
will be meeting with them before that
meeting
committee meeting is to discuss with
them so they're both in receipt as you
know of a revenue grant from us and as
part of that revenue grant we set out
criteria and um
sort of kpis for them to to
to try and meet and
that year so the meetings that we'll
have with them uh will be to look at
their progress against meeting those
particular kpis the support they've
given whether there's been um
you know what
their trend data whether there's an
emerging need that we hadn't anticipated
that we might need to or they might need
to refocus some of their work so that's
what we're expecting from um
from the presentations that will come to
your committee i think next month it's
been scheduled for
and i think depending on the outcome of
whether or not you're satisfied with the
information that comes back at that
point that might be best to then
determine whether or not there's
anything else further you would like for
them to do because until we got some of
that information and certainly they have
been working very hard in terms of
against those kpis but until they
provided and presented some of that
information i think it would be quite
difficult to scope that review now it
might be worthwhile waiting for that to
happen
and to have the opportunity to ask
questions at that point and if you would
then think that further scrutiny is
required then we do so at that point
that would just be my my observations my
advice
thank you vicky roston do you want to
make a comment
no that just i agree with what vicky is
vicky said we do work closely with with
the um four citizens of ice bureaus that
we do fund through revenue grants on an
annual basis
as you're probably aware the mid-suffolk
cob and sudbury and district do get the
largest
revenue grants from us as organizations
councillor wallan do you want to respond
to
vicki or royster
um
yes chair i would like to respond
because
councillor scarf has set out
the purpose of the review
and if they don't know what the purpose
of the review is how will they know what
to present to us i would have i would
have thought it would be helpful
to
to them
to
have this information which is in this
draft scoping document um
because we don't we don't want to hear
about everything else not here about
this
we
there are only a very few
uh items that we we
we would really like to hear about in
detail
and in the limited amount of time that
they will have for their presentations
this is
if this is agreed this is what we this
is what we want need to know i don't
think there's anything contentious there
but i think it will be helpful
to to to us as a as a committee
um
otherwise
uh we'll hear from them
and then we'll then we'll draft a
scoping document and we'll be a month
further down the line
and we'll have had we'll have had
two bites of the of the cherry and we
can do i think we can do it all in one
um
[Music]
unless the officer's got some
particular concern about anything that's
in this giraffe scoping document then
um yeah i would i would far rather we
went ahead and
and scoped rather than
waited wait and see what they've got to
say
vicky would you like to respond to that
yes please uh apologies council i
thought we were talking about slightly
different purposes there i agree with
everything that's listed in this scope
and that's exactly what we would be
expecting from that presentation it was
my understanding that you want to do
something separate to that meeting in
december if it's the same thing then
that's absolutely fine
and so if my memory serves me well some
of the presentations that were provided
last year did focus on a lot of this
information so the meetings that roy and
i will have ahead of that presentation
uh in december will be to go through the
scoping um once it's been confirmed and
agreed by yourselves with them to make
sure that they do incorporate all the
points that you've listed in that in
that document so i thought we were
talking about two different exercises
and i really wanted to just save us
some time and just do the one exercise
but if that's what you're considering
that's absolutely fine
we're absolutely agreed with the content
of the scoping document
do you want to respond to that counselor
i know i'm delighted to hear that
they've um
i i i just was a bit concerned there was
something contentious in there that um
either our officers or citizens advice
had some reason for not wishing to
to to to inform us upon so that's great
i think it still it still requires us
then to fully in the other empty boxes
and
i'll be subject to what other members of
the committee
have to say before we do that that would
be my suggestion that we we just get on
and fill up the scoping document okay so
first of all can we
are you happy that you take questions
first
from the committee yeah
well yeah i'm happy i'm happy to take
questions
um i think we just need to
go with it counselor pineal
thank you madam chairman um
my question is
what is the purpose of
completing the scoping document if we're
going to be getting
a full presentation in a month's time
from
the relevant offices that covers all of
these points i don't see what value this
can possibly add to anything
because presumably at the point of which
we get the presentation we will be able
to
question the officers in in
as as much as we need to
castle
i think the advice we were given last
time was that if we filled in the
scoping document it would focus not just
focus the minds of the citizens advice
people but also focus our minds on
for instance what are our expected
outcomes
um
i mean
perhaps perhaps we we could ask emily
whether
she feels that it would be beneficial to
this committee and to citizen's advice
if we did complete the scoping exercise
or whether she feels it will get the
same the same outcome either way
thank you chair um the purpose of the
scoping document is as much for the
committee's benefit as for the people
coming to present information to you
because really the
desired outcome from the scoping
exercises to set out what you hope to
achieve by undertaking the review and so
it's really to inform um you know who
who do you want to come to present
information what kinds of questions do
you want to ask them so that you can
focus your activity
on achieving an outcome that really adds
value to the authority or to the
residents or or to the organization that
you're you're looking into
um so
i would almost say it's weighted in
favor of the committee as opposed to
those presenting in terms of its
usefulness
i do think it's appropriate for you to
be be clear on the purpose of this
review
i think officers have described quite
clearly
their expectation and the expectation of
the representatives from ca
and
they've mentioned that the questions
that you've posed in your scoping
document um match that brief
so i think it is useful to share it
whether you need to put any more into
the document that you've already got in
front of you i think is is for you to
decide
but i do think we need to be cautious
about not extending the scope too far
and then making it impossible for the
representative representatives to
prepare that information to present to
you in december
thank you emily councillor wallam i've
got to say i'm i am slightly confused
myself can you just explain to us what
you would like the committee to do just
now
um i think that would be helpful to all
members
um
yes thank you chair yeah we've got the
table we've got the table document
um and
when when i when i i printed it off
naughty made uh and and i just started
filling in the boxes so for instance i
feel we need to to explain what the
outcomes we expect and i've written in
there
confirmation that the cas are well
managed and adequately funded the
continuity of the service to the
communities they serve
so that we we only focus on that aspect
we want to know that we want to know
that they're well managed we want to
know that they're well funded and we
want to know that they've got continuity
of service
one of the concerns and the reason for
the that in there is that um
some some time ago when i was speaking
to the
chief executive officer at stone market
he was this is during during covid's
more severe kobe times we're not out of
it yet
his concern was that at the start of
lockdown a number of their volunteers
felt that
they were vulnerable
and they didn't really want to have to
get they didn't want to go into the
building and they didn't want to have to
get to grips with the technology that
was involved around um uh virtual
meetings so my understanding was at that
time there were a number of volunteers
who
um
didn't continue
but i believe more recently there are
other volunteers
who are more more used to
using it so they've got
new and different volunteers
so that's a good thing
but the downside is that they've lost
the people who've been trained they've
gained some people who they now have to
train it's you know i do i i feel we
just need to know it as two district
councils that the service
is
you know
there will be continuity of service to
the communities
but
well i need some clarification councilor
welland because
i understand
the first page of that scoping document
i understand all those questions that
you're raising
what i what i'm trying to grasp
is by
completing the rest of the form how
that's going to benefit
the committee the committee have got to
be prepared
to ask the question of the citizens
advice services
and i just
i just need some clarification why it's
necessary at this point
to complete all the rest of the form
emily can i have some advice on that
well could i just say i think it will
provide focus to the meeting i think it
the meet it will be
much
easier to conduct the meeting if we know
what our expected outcomes are rather
than we just have a discussion about how
things are going
um
jay i'm just being advised by officers
sitting with me that
there are some outcomes actually listed
in the grant agreement that we have with
ca
so i think it may be possible for
officers to take the scoping document
away
populate it share it with ca and then
make sure that committee members have
sight of it before the meeting um so i
think we could take that exercise away
and and fill in the rest of the boxes if
if the committee would like us to um
rather than you having to to fill it in
on the spot today
thank you
yes i actually um
thank you emily for that because um
when we had the last presentation from
the cas um
the the comment that councillor wellam
wants to put in his outcomes was
actually the outcomes that we talked
about which was the continuity of
funding for the services uh and the
issues regard around people uh you know
leaving the service and having to
recruit and train new
new um supporters and volunteers which i
believe the the um exec chief executive
of the stone market branch uh put
very clearly as to what their plans was
and they
as part of the the funding arrangement
the these lcas do have kpis and outcomes
that they have to achieve and i think
from our my point of view anyway that's
what we should be holding them to he
said are they achieving those outcomes
and if they are not
then what is it what needs to be done to
help them achieve them
and i i don't see there's going to be
any value added for us to sit here and
try and fill in these boxes today
hello phillips
um i understand what counselor
is saying but i think there is a need
for
clarification from
four members it wasn't expected that the
committee fill in this form it was
expected that they were a councillor
well and was given the okay to go and
get this filled in
correctly so that we could have the
information to
committee as i understand it i may be
wrong than that
does it is that what you understood
counselor
my understanding was that um
before this meeting it would be filled
in as much as it could be in terms of
well
it's page three it's it's the purpose
but that we would give a steer
on what we wanted to get out of it
um and but i'm quite i'm quite i'm quite
happy i'm quite happy for the officers
to complete the form um very happy if
that's if that's the case but i think it
would be helpful to the officers and to
us
if we did
um
discuss very briefly what what we would
like to see as outcomes
and for me it's to ensure that there is
continuity of service that they have
planned for the future
thank you council welcome councillor
carter
uh thank you
i had wondered if it would be possible
to
include or broaden within this
a
a subject regarding the mental health of
the volunteers we do know that things
have changed they have to
have had to focus on technology
we also know from our own experience
with our own offices and ourselves when
you are focused mainly on a screen and
separate from people with additional
stresses
and there's different it's just
additional barriers
i want to know if they currently have
the best
technology available if they have the
best support available and if there's
more support that can be added what can
we do to help them what
you know and also
specifically in a question
addressed it and asked
what help would they like from us if
there is anything they specifically
would could think about in the ideal
world
what can we do for them
because we've got we we've at this
moment in time we have
tasks implemented we have
um ideals that we want to implement in
here
they have their own agenda they have
their own to help as many people as
possible
how can we help them
how do they want us to help them rather
than how do we take old into account see
if that could be specifically put in
there
more in a dark but
in the best best
put better
more consistently than i can put it but
how can we help them and if we can put
that in the part of the document
thank you councillor carter uh vicky
have you made a note of that
thank you very much would that be
helpful councillor carter
yes thank you very much
thank you madam chair i think we could
be in danger here of um
asking questions that maybe need to be
asked at the review
um rather than us going into sort of you
know my new details i think these are
the questions that need to be asked at
the appropriate time rather than us
pulling it apart now um
i i don't know what to think about this
scoping document
part of me thinks that it may actually
tie the hands
of the
the ca a little bit and that they may be
so intent on filling this out with the
the details
because this is what i would call the
the known unknown this is the stuff we
know that we would like to know but
there might be stuff that the unknown
unknown that we don't know is there and
if the cas are sort of intent on filling
out this document there may be things
that they would have added to reports
but they didn't know that we that we
that we wanted does that make sense
sorry
um i'm just got concerned we're going to
get into a sort of administrative
um
task that really we don't need to do
we've heard from the officers that
they're happy to take this scoping
document away
i
do we need to
make any more comments on that to the
officers
councillor welland
chair i was uh trying to get my head
around making a proposal that we
not that we don't talk about it anymore
but basically that we don't talk about
it anymore by
by way of saying that we've we have made
our we've made our comments to the
officers and the officers will arrange
for
um
the the scoping to be
carried out and the ca is informed
whether that whether that's can be put
into a proposal that we you know we we
draw a line under it now and leave the
rest of the offices council phillips as
you were here representing councillor
scarf have you got any comments you wish
to add to that
i fully endorse that and i think it's
something we need to do rather than just
say
we'll get this at the next meme we must
do this
we must do what
the filling in the
scope you want to pull it in now no no
no take it away
for the offer
yes
i think um
yeah
to a drug chair might be helpful because
we do another draft resolution that
possibly might help members in their
decision so
that the committee resolves to approve
the scoping document included in the
table papers with the amendments as
discussed at the meeting and that
delegation is given to the monitoring
officer to complete the remainder of the
scoping document
in consultation with possibly
other officers present if that's
acceptable
um
i i wonder if we could add to it um
that that it
it there's a timeline for that and that
if we receive it before the meeting
we could um the scoping document has
could be included as part of the agenda
bundle
for the next week if that's acceptable
we wouldn't necessarily need to put that
in the resolution i'd say
cancer but we can put that in with the
agenda bundle when it's um no i that's
not what i'm asking for i'm asking it
before the agenda bundle and i'll
explain later why
chair i think the uh governance officer
is doing an admirable job at trying not
to commit me to a time
table so thank you for that um but
committee i'm more than happy to look at
that in in perhaps the next week and
make sure that committee members have
sight of it before the final copy is
shared with ca okay
does that satisfy your concern counselor
equino
so
shall we proceed are we ready to go
forward
we've had the proposal we don't actually
have a although i've read it out here we
don't actually have a personal secondary
no no no but we've got the
recommendation yeah so i'm looking for a
proposal
and councillor phillips to second thank
you
so we now go to the electronic vote
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
council phillips can i take your photo
four thank you council phillips
thank you chair that's all folks now
receiving this unanimous vote for the
proposal thank you thank you members uh
we now go on to the forthcoming decision
list
oh councillor phillip sorry
as unanimous vote for council phillips
so you can relay that back to councillor
scar thank you councillor phillips
thank you
vicky and royston
for your support
so we're now going to the forthcoming
decision list are there any comments on
that by members anything of
interest that they need to raise
so that's for nothing
robert thank you
now we go on to the
items 10 and 11 which are the
work plans for mid-suffolk and babera
overview and scrutiny
committees
are there any comments on that
councillor thank you yeah just just i
think it's probably a typo topographic
level or something under 20th of
december and 16th of december of the mid
suffolk the review of local cities is
advice the lead officer is not the
assistant director planning for growth
so we just need to we just need to put
the correct title in there for the
um but otherwise
i'm content with
those
any comments
no
um
that's it we're happy with the work
plans
um so the work plans are for noting
robert
well members we've come to the end of
the meeting
can i
answer it
too soon cancer
yeah uh well i'm glad that uh we've
had a successful overview and scrutiny
uh
madam chairman
one thing that concerns me
about our meetings and and meetings in
general
at this council
is the time it takes us to get the
minutes of these meetings
and i'm concerned for two reasons for
one is that
i don't know about others but one memory
fades with time and so
being able to decide whether on the
veracity and content of the minute um
the ability to do that fades with that
time and and i i i know the officers
have a lot to do
but i i failed to understand why
um we cannot get the minutes way before
the next meeting
when things would still be fresh in our
minds and it doesn't apply just to this
to this committee
it applies to every committee that i sit
on in mid-southwark
and i don't think it's good practice
and the other thing i notice with the
the minute of the meeting is that unlike
other
um
committees we don't appear to list the
attendees of that of the overview and
through committee so it wasn't clear to
me whether people were abstaining
because they weren't present at the last
meeting or they just didn't like the
content of the minutes
so
i think i would like to suggest that we
look into this and do something about it
emily can we um review that
yes chair i'll take those points away
and discuss them with the i think that
manager the cultures would want to
discuss that with you
thank you
councillor phillips
just just a quick comment on the
abstention side of things so i quite
understand
uh what counselor kim yong
sorry paul
was saying and i think it's fairly clear
that if you weren't happy with the
minute you would vote against them but
um to know that someone's abstained
because they weren't present at the
meeting is is quite valuable
i actually agree with that i as you've
raised it
because abstentions in most committees
is because you're
abstaining from the vote
but in fact for a lot of us today the
abstention was because we were not
present at the last meeting and that's
actually not quite clear is it um
does that need to be clarified only
sorry chad could you repeat that well we
we have a vote result which is an
abstention
now in many committees the abstention is
because we actually don't agree
or we're not we're not agreeing to
either either commit to or for or
against
uh but in fact our abstentions today
because i i was one of those that was
absent it was the abstention
number was because we were absent and
you're saying that's not that's not
clear is it
it's quite useful to know
if there is specific reason for an
abstention if someone's not happy with
the minutes they should vote against
them but to abstain you you really
should know why they're abstaining yes
i think unfortunately in committees we
do get abstentions when people really
should be against
well minutes is different i think it's
uh mainly due to the minutes abstentions
that paul was talking about yeah okay is
everybody councillor custom
yeah i just wanted to say that i think
if um counselors abstain because they
don't agree with the minutes they're not
doing their job properly and that's not
how they should be looking at the
minutes but i think in abstention
because you weren't at the meeting
is um it's it's very sensible i would
abstain if i wasn't at a meeting because
i wouldn't comment on the minutes but um
i think if we get to that process
and the member hasn't
pointed out why they've got a problem
with the um
the minutes and why they're not voting
for them
um that's that's a bit of a failing from
that member because they should really
be bringing that up whether that happens
or not i don't know i quite support that
councillor gold
um correct me here but i thought we were
voting on the accuracy of the minutes
not on whether we agreed with the
content of them
so if we have read them and we've
brought up any inaccuracies
surely we we agree with them
emily
i'm just conscious that um we're
discussing items that weren't on the
agenda and the meeting is still open at
the moment um but just to give you my
advice
um abstentions should really be used as
a last resort so
you should always try to vote either for
or against to make decisive action
we wouldn't ever record individuals
reasoning for abstaining but of course
when you're speaking to the motion you
might set out that reasoning and that it
makes a lot of sense for you to explain
that if you are going to abstain on the
point of minutes
you don't actually have to abstain by
virtue of not having been at the meeting
that the minutes relate to but i do
understand for lots of counsellors you
prefer to do that because you feel it's
not appropriate to comment on the
accuracy of a meeting where you weren't
actually present so it's not that it's
not allowed but equally it's not
mandatory
thank you chair thank you emily i think
actually that ought to be clarified
across all councillors
uh for certainly that the intake of 2019
of which i won
um abstention was seen as um
because you were absent
counselor
yeah just very quickly i think you're
about to move on to date of next meeting
um just to confirm that it is a joint
overview of your scrutiny meeting on the
20th and the date listed for mid-support
on the 16th
um
now that's that that meeting
those two meetings are the same and
they're both going to take place on the
20th and i think um
i'm not sure whether we've formally
agreed not to have the meeting on the
16th but we're not having a meeting on
the 16th can i have a clarification on
that robert that's correct so the
meeting in december will be a joint
meeting as discussed that was um we
discussed that earlier this uh last week
um the next meetings that will be
separate will be the budgetary meetings
that will be taking place in january
is that okay that's absolutely fine
thank you before before i conclude the
meeting and see members are anxious to
get home
i just want to say that robert
our governance officer is leaving the
council
and will not be with us at our next
joint overview and scrutiny committee
and
i mean my my time
knowing you robert has been in the last
couple of years but a lot of the members
of norni for a lot longer and i want to
say thank you
for all the help and support
that you've given various committees
because we met you on plane and such and
so
thank you so much for all the work that
you do on our behalf and we wish you
well in your new post in colchester
borough council
and i'm sure members will
join me in our best wishes for him
right thank you members that concludes
the meeting